the villagers of taparto in northwest
colombia used their bare hands to search
for the children trapped under a
mountain of felled trees and mud a
landslide buried this rural school in a
matter of seconds 22 students were
inside
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
three of them died two six-year-old
girls and one five-year-old boy
a father hopelessly hugging one of them
the other 19 were found alive when
rescue teams arrived with earth-moving
equipment
the national army the national police
and rescue officers are helping this
educational institution where a
landslide caught young students unaware
as they were taking class inside as you
can see we are using excavators to help
with the emergency
armed forces are at the top helping
rescue the children who are alive
this is the moment the rescuers heard a
voice under the rubble
they later find a little girl still
alive
this landslide was just one of a number
of avalanches and floods hitting the
northwest of colombia in recent weeks
dozens of families had to be relocated
near medellin on thursday
last wednesday thousands were affected
by floods when the sinu and san jorge
rivers burst their banks
experts say the heavy rains plaguing
much of colombia are due to the cyclical
la nina weather phenomenon that happens
every three to five years but its
effects are now being amplified by
climate change and with them the risk of
more tragedies like this one alessandra
al jazeera